hey guys what with the new rockstars I'm
Sebastian Avengers infinity war hit
theaters and y'all going crazy for you
won't stop tweeting me about videos I
can only go so quick and I'm already
such a slow human being now I'm sure you
guys can already guess based on the
title of this video that we're going to
be talking about spoilers for an
infinity war moving forward alright now
let's discuss the soul stone the only
stone that wasn't explored in previous
Marvel movies we know it's one of the
six Infinity stones and when you use
together they can rewrite the universe
and the user of these stones is
basically a god intro Thanos old
testicle chin has a simple goal to
balance the boogers by deleting a bunch
of beings from existence basically half
of all life but anyway Thanos needed to
unite all the Infinity stones for this
to work and this leads to an adventure
to vermeer with Gamora to find the soul
stone but here's a couple questions well
that is a soul stone what does it do
exactly like we have a pretty good idea
of what it did in the movie kind that
we'll review it but what specifically
did it do to help Latinos accomplish his
goal also why was the red skull
protecting it and what was that weird
pool world we visited at the end of the
movie and why it was Gamora there so
many questions that start with the easy
ones like what is the soul stone and
what does it do well according to the
comics
it's the Infinity gem say did a little
shout-out to you comic book nerds the
Infinity gem that has control over all
life but more specifically the user
could control all living and dead souls
mean they could obtain control of them
or steal them for their own use whatever
you want to put their souls into a
machine to make smoothies you could do
that I don't know why you would be girls
to control all life in the universe if
you used it correctly yes all life which
Thanos does in a way the soul stone is
also a gateway of sorts to a pocket
dimension where souls of people who have
interacted with the soul stone reside
kind of cool little sliver their soul
gets sucked out into it it's kind of
like this idyllic utopia but sometimes
it's more of a prison depends on who's
right in the story now remember all this
because it will be on the final next big
question how is the soul stone used in
the movie well we see the sacrifice that
Thanos makes to obtain the stone which
isn't normally how you get the stone in
the comics it's usually just in Adam
warlocks forehead or is just sitting
somewhere but being honest I did and
growing this change and then we see him
add it to his gauntlet but not really
use it in battle as far as we can tell
or did he my guess is that for this
halving of the universe to truly stick
he needed more power than just the
reality stone I'm thinking that the soul
stone tapped into all of the souls of
all living things in the universe and
from there
random people were deleted from
existence but back to fighting with it
my guess that it was only used like one
or two times mainly when he hears Thanos
tell Tony that he's not the only one
burdened with knowledge also it could
have helped him identify which of the
Doctor Strange doppelgangers was the
real sorcerer but back to that burden
line because I think there's a couple
theories attached to it that are pretty
fun one specifically states that this
line is linked to the soul stone meaning
that the stone may have given Thanos the
knowledge of all of those around him who
he was fighting at the time by tapping
into their souls or possibly he's
tapping into all souls that's why he
feels burdened the red skull does
describe the soul stone is having a
wisdom to it which does back that up
just a little bit next why was the red
skull protecting it and what is Vermeer
Boromir in the comics is the home to a
race called the former reptilians
snake-like creature that is actually
part of the Kree Empire an alien race
that has popped up a few times in the
MCU both in movies and TV shows
as for the red school I feel like his
appearance ties back to Thanos in the
comics mainly because of his ghostly
appearance and duty to the stone I feel
like his role is more similar to
mistress death in the comics and anyway
since red skull is responsible for
overseeing the soulstone and there needs
to be a sacrifice specifically a death
to retrieve the stone I feel like he's a
stand-in for her kind of also the
current guardians of the galaxy run and
infinity countdown saga revealed that
Gamora is sort of an overseer of the
soul stone except it's not her it's a
sliver of her soul that is trapped in
the soul stone so there might be a
connection there since red school
doesn't look like he's going anywhere
soon if that makes sense anyways next
what is this reflection pool world that
Thanos visits before everyone dissolves
away I think you all might already know
based on what I've said earlier but I
believe this to be the MCU version of
the soul world the pocket dimension
inside of the soul stone I believe that
this place is just a small corner of the
soul worlds idyllic landscape there's
also fun fan theory that the reason they
visited this place momentarily is
because he actually ended up there think
about this
what if Thanos was a part of the
universe that got wiped out he
teleported away before everyone started
turning to dust in a last shot we see of
him is on an idyllic farm smiling and
happy maybe he's finally found peace and
passed on possibly being sucked into the
soul world either way he will return
based on the text at the end credits of
this movie so who knows and final
question guys is Gamora actually dead
well like we know the soul requires a
sacrifice in order to obtain it and we
now know that the stone in the comics is
also a portal to a pocket dimension
which we probably saw and the stone
likes to collect little slivers of souls
so here's a theory that has been
circulating online what if the stone
actually saved Gamora what if her Souls
zapped into the stone after her death
Gamora has spent some time in the soul
world in the comics and she just one day
decided without a warlock and pip the
troll to return to our universe to be
fair she didn't exactly die to go into
the soul world in the first place but
still there remains a chance that she
could just pop right out of that stone
and back into the land of the living
during the finale of Avengers 4 or maybe
guardians vol 3 what do you guys think
how will the Dead Boys & Girls get
undead 'add in the next movie be nice in
the comments when you write your
theories and hey maybe go check out my
nerdy podcast only stupid answers little
plug if you like these videos you'll
like that but anyways like this video
first before you go anywhere share with
your friends and subscribe for more
content if you got questions about
infinity war we probably have a video
for it you're very welcome go think Erik
Bosse as well ei vas on Twitter but I'm
at Sam basher on Twitter and I'll see
you guys next time